alors 2023 s'ouvre aussi dans un
contexte compliqué pour les communes
pour l'ensemble des Français vous l'avez
rappelé d'ailleurs dans l'édito du
magazine de Maurepas de ce mois de
janvier une guerre en Europe qui a
entraîné une crise énergétique une crise
économique alors face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie il y a la solution de
la sobriété énergétique qui s'impose
dans les communes comment a-t-elle été
prise en compte à Maurepas et ce qu'il y
a des prévoyez de faire des choses cette
année en matière de sobriété énergétique
alors je dirais que l'avantage aussi
qu'on a sur le territoire de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin c'est
que bah en communique beaucoup entre
nous et qu'on travaille beaucoup entre
nous et que on sait coordonner avec
l'ensemble des mers et que sobriété de
nous avons mis en place il est surtout
axé sur l'extinction de l'éclairage
public qui nous permet de faire des
économies qui est très bien excepté
d'ailleurs par nos habitants c'est aussi
la bête des températures dans les
équipements publics dans la limite de ce
qui est permis par par les décès donc un
petit changement d'habitude mais qui est
accepté par nos habitants ils
comprennent évidemment cette volonté de
faire des efforts et en même temps de
protéger
l'environnement et puis la planète et
c'est aussi un changement de de
mentalité avec peut-être une perspective
aussi nous nous engageons dans les
travaux que nous présentons dans nos
établissements nos c'est-à-dire les
passions LED par exemple on a accéléré
relation en LED de nos éclairages de nos
équipements publics pour faire des
économies d'énergie c'est 30% à peu près
l'économie d'énergie parce que
il est vrai que c'est un contexte très
compliqué pour les collectivités
déjà subi en 2022 c'est un surplus
budget
800 et donc
c'était quand même une somme importante
il faut qu'on continue nos efforts mais
pour autant
j'ose espérer que la situation va pas
durer parce que je ne sais pas comment
on va pour ensuite
j'allais dire tenir l'équilibre de nos
budgets scientificat nous n'avons pas
pour faire face cette augmentation
exponentielle de l'énergie que nous
n'avions pas prévu alors la connexion
n'est pas très bonne en excuse auprès de
nos téléspectateurs alors sur cet angle
de la rénovation énergétique il me
semble qu'à Maurepas il y aura un
engagement cette année en tout cas la
définition d'un projet pour rénover les
trois écoles du centre-ville c'est bien
ça c'est c'est
dans vos projets
oui alors depuis que je suis devenu né
en 2014 on a lancé un grand plan de
rénovation de nos bâtiments communaux on
en a à peu près 55 donc l'attaché lourde
et nous avons déjà rénové quelques
écoles et nous allons continuer
notamment les trois plus grandes écoles
où la plus grande école de l'école de la
même me donne qui est associé à l'école
de la haute vitesse et de descente des
écoles maternelles comme c'est l'école
de la même donne l'école qui est déjà
suffisamment
qui accueille plus de trois élèves nous
avons l'ambition d'engager des travaux
de rénovation
et aussi dans une réflexion de
transformer l'une des écoles maternelles
en école élémentaire donc là on a lancé
les études de faisabilité et nous avons
déjà engagé des concertations d'élèves
sur ce sujet donc on démarre j'allais
dire l'ambition mais c'est une ambition
qui va se dérouler sur plusieurs années
en contenu du coût de restructuration de
ces trois écoles et d'agrandissement
également il y a un autre dossier dont
on parle depuis 2019 dans la commune de
Maurepas c'est bien sûr cette du marché
on se rappelle qui a été détruite par un
incendie en juillet 2019 il y a une
phase de concertation qui avait été
lancée pour décider de la construction
d'une nouvelle halle qu'est-il prévu du
coup cette année est-ce que les travaux
de cette nouvelle halle vont pouvoir
démarrer
oui alors ils vont commencer en 2023 on
a perdu un peu de temps sur le dossier à
cause j'allais dire de l'inflation du
coût des matières premières dont on est
aussi victime dans nos marchés publics
du marché en fait évidemment les frais
donc c'est très attendu par nos
habitants et par nos commerçants pas mal
de consultations vous l'avez rappelé
donc début des travaux spirés avec une
livraison prévue en 2004 donc une halle
qui fera la place belle au bois aux
énergies renouvelables avec récupérateur
d'eau de pluie avec panneau solaire des
états commerçants qui seront pérennes
puisque c'était l'une de leur volonté
également les halles du marché
construit aujourd'hui n'ont rien à voir
avec celle du passé donc beaucoup plus
de confort un confort visuel un confort
en termes aussi
j'allais dire de circulation d'air bref
tout est pensé pour que on ait
centre-ville et une loi du marché
beaucoup dynamique et beaucoup plus
attractive qu'auparavant donc ça avance
Nicolas d'André qui est avec ton plateau
vous aviez une question une question
puisqu'on parle de commerce il y a les
halles de Maurepas pour les commerçants
les vendeurs et les maraîchers mais
parlons des espaces commerciaux un peu
plus grands notamment Paris Ouest ce que
vous partagez aussi avec la commune de
Coignières le forum JB cette zone
commerciale est-ce qu'il y a des
nouvelles étapes qui vont qui vont
intervenir en 2023 alors je sais que ça
concerne la commune de Maurepas mais
c'est aussi plus globalement
l'intercommunalité de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est
concernée
oui vous avez raison alors la zone
d'activité Paris Ouest que nous avons en
commun avec la ville de Coignières nous
avons mené avec l'aide de l'État à une
étude sur ce qu'on appelle repenser la
périphérie commerciale qui a débouché
sur un schéma directeur de développement
qui n'est pas si simple parce que en
fait les valeurs fontières très
importantes sur le secteur et plus de
180 propriétaires différentes donc du
côté de Coignières on a cette
redynamisation du forum du gibet et du
côté de Maurepas ce qu'on appelle le
programme Éthique sia là où s'est
installé cultura s'est installé
également de nouveaux Kiabi et là on a
un projet aussi d'extension et de
revalorisation des espaces commerciaux
existants avec de nouvelles enseignes
aussi qui vont arriver dans des locaux
et des espaces qui sont beaucoup plus
tournés aussi vers le développement
durable et beaucoup plus qualitatif donc
une zone commerciale et industrielle je
le rappelle qui est en pleine évolution
mutation c'est une zone d'activité qui a
été créée il y a plus de 50 ans et donc
voilà ça fait petit à petit et en effet
elle se redynamise au temps et on s'y
attelle avec le maire de punir puisque
vous parlez des zones commerciales on le
sait en bordure de nationale 10 j'en
profite pour parler de ce sujet de
circulation il y a un point central un
que vous partagez avec les communes
justement de Coignières mais aussi de la
verrière c'est ce carrefour de la
malmedone en 2019 50 ans en Yvelines
avait lancé un projet de réaménagement
et cette année c'est une enquête
publique qui est prévue sur sur le sujet
on va avoir du concret aussi dès cette
année 2023 on imagine un projet
peut-être un peu retardé aussi avec le
covid 19
oui vous avez raison parce que ce projet
a été annoncé auprès des habitants je
crois que c'était en 2019 et puis une
concertation préalable en à cette
période là rien ne s'était passé depuis
donc aujourd'hui c'est mené par la
Direction des Routes donc l'état en
collaboration évidemment avec le 50 ans
de Yvelines la région Île-de-France le
département des Yvelines et donc c'est
un vrai projet structurant pour pour nos
communes avec une enquête publique qui
va commencer d'ici le printemps
donc évidemment la ville de Maurepas est
favorable avec nous l'espérons aussi
quelques ajustements avec notamment les
deux activités qui sont bordées qui
bordent la nationalisme et qu'il faudra
justement à terme déplacé mais sinon
c'est un projet vraiment très utile
parce que ça va permettre de la
réouverture de l'axe départemental la
départementale 13 pour permettre aux
habitants d'accéder directement à la
gare de La Verrière donc un projet
structurant qui en a bien besoin qui
était en tout cas il y en a bien besoin
pour revitaliser ce secteur et pour
mieux le sécuriser et en tout cas mieux
sécuriser les accès et repenser aussi
j'allais dire les mobilités douces qui
aujourd'hui est un pas économique amorpa
également côté circulation une
reconfiguration du boulevard miserer
pour cette année 2023
oui tout à fait on parle de circulation
de boulevard miserek est
qui poursuit le carrefour des pyramides
qui va verser en cours donc un boulevard
qui
j'allais dire connaît à peu près 9000
véhicules par jour donc c'est pas le
plus structurant qu'on comparé au
boulevard de la Loire qui est plutôt à
16000 véhicules par jour mais qui était
un boulevard qui est on le voit sur les
photos qui est surdimensionné donc on va
le passer en deux fois une voie on va y
recréer des places de stationnement le
long du centre médical des pyramides qui
lui est en train de s'étendre avec
l'arrivée d'une IRM dans quelle quelques
mois et puis c'est aussi de retravailler
les espaces paysagers de replanter des
arbres bref un aménagement plus
qualitatif avec une pacification de la
circulation avec les différents usages
que l'on connaît avec la mobilité douce
les vélos les trottinettes les piétons
donc voilà ça fait partie du panel de
tous les travaux que nous menons sur le
territoire de Maurepas
il y en a d'autres on va reconstruire
aussi du centre de loisirs primaires et
le seul centre de loisirs primaire de
Maurepas qui n'avait pas connu de
travaux de 1983 donc là on détruit en
construit totalement avec un bâtiment
qui soit tourné vers le développement
durable également sur le même site donc
voilà nous avons son nous avons déjà
répondu à près de 67% de notre projet de
mandat sur les 85 Honda sur lequel j'ai
été rayures 2020 on a déjà atteint taux
de réalisation de lancement de 67% juste
avant qu'on passe à l'interview Express
qui l'exercice classique que l'on
propose Homer durant ce mois de janvier
un projet original aussi qui va avoir le
jour à Maurepas c'est celui d'une
microforêt urbaine qui va pousser le
long de la nationale 10 c'est dans le
square de l'Esterel dans le quartier de
la Jo les habitants les écoliers la
mairie vont planter des arbres des
arbustes il y a d'ailleurs un
rendez-vous qui a organisé pour les
habitants le 11 février à 10 heures
pourquoi ce projet quel est l'intérêt
peut porter un tel projet dans votre
commune
oui alors c'est un projet qui nous tient
à coop à coeur parce que l'équipe
municipale on est déjà mobilisé depuis
de nombreuses années sur le
développement durable et la protection
de l'environnement on a créé des espaces
paysagers on a restructuré des espaces
publics en y plantant des arbres on a un
projet de 500 arbres sur le mandat on a
également mis en place et planter des
vergers participatifs et d'autres
actions je veux pas d'en faire toute la
litanie ce soir mais en tout cas cette
microforêt cette nouveauté sur le
territoire de Maurepas on s'inspire
d'une méthode japonaise c'est un projet
qui est piloté par ma première adjointe
Myriam debucquoy et on avait un espace
qui était inutilisé depuis de nombreuses
années en bordure de national 10 protégé
par un mur anti-bruit à proximité très
proche des pavillons et à la place d'une
ancienne de station-service désaffectée
donc le terrain est totalement dépollué
on a à peu près 1300 mètres carrés près
de 1950 arbustes et arbres pour que
d'ici 20 ans ça soit suffisamment dent
pour que ça soit
donc ça va être un niveau de fraîcheur
ça va être capteur de carbone également
et on est associé avec référence fun qui
est une association qui milite justement
pour
forêt et c'est
par l'entreprise Pampers donc c'est
autofinancé totalement pour un coup de
27 500 euros non seulement ce coûte rien
mais en plus c'est bon pour la planète
des arbres donc voilà c'est une belle
opération et on va engager
des plantations avec les enfants des
écoles et puis des habitants de Maurepas
qui voudront
pour terminer cet entretien on passe à
l'interview express
[Musique]
Grégory garissier je vais vous poser 5
questions c'est des questions que nous
avons posé à l'ensemble des maires de 50
ans en Yvelines qui sont venus dans ce 7
8 en plateau alors une exigence des
réponses courtes oui un nom un pour ou
contre suffisent parfois une explication
mais je vais vous demander de pas
dépasser les 20 secondes d'explications
sur sur ces questions première question
Grégory Garcia ce qu'en 2023 vous
augmenterez les impôts locaux à Maurepas
alors à l'heure actuelle rien n'est
prévu encore à ce stade on prépare les
arbitrages
certaines communes ont fait le choix de
passer une imitation de 30 km/h pour
leurs axes est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre une telle idée
je pense que le 30 km/h s'applique dans
certaines zones c'est utile voire même
10 km parfois mais sur la totalité de la
commune non il faut déjà faire respecter
le 5 dans d'autres communes également
dans certaines communes on a fait le
choix de passer à des cantines bio
est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
peut-être une incitation du du lieu dans
les cantines
alors c'est une bonne question et c'est
déjà obligatoire vous savez c'est 20% de
bio prévus par la loi égalim et 30% de
produits issus du circuits courts donc
j'allais dire elle est déjà de facto à
20% et c'est un coup c'est une rotation
de 30 de 20% du coup du repas si tu
trouves on devait tout passer audio et
pour être plus précis on a aussi une
problématique de production de terre bio
de gaz agricoles bio donc il faudrait
qu'on soit aussi en capacité de
d'acheter en tout cas des produits bio
si on devait passer à 100%. donc déjà
respectons la loi gabyme aujourd'hui qui
a quand même des des conséquences et qui
n'est pas si simple en termes de
d'objectif européens on a vu dans
l'actualité malheureusement des maires
et des élus qui ont été victimes
d'agression de menaces est-ce que vous
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions vous
avez déjà eu peur physiquement
je n'ai jamais eu peur physiquement mais
parfois il est arrivé qu'en un moment
plus tendu que d'autres notamment quand
j'ai eu affaire par exemple des
occupations illicites de terrain mais ça
c'est toujours très très bien passé
parce que évidemment pas que il faut
qu'on soit un peu formé dans le dans
l'exercice et les élus chargés de
l'embellissement de la ville qui a eu
affaire et une agression physique parce
que elle avait des elle avait repéré un
une personne qui avait déposé des
déchets sauvages sur la République
et il y a eu l'agression physique donc
elle a déposé plainte et donc mais ça
fait partie aussi des contexte il y a
quand même de plus en plus violente ou
les barrières j'allais dire lâche et
donc il faut quand même très attentif
d'ailleurs la société des maires de
France parce qu'on dénoncer qu'on avait
une augmentation
physique Warren berbal
près des mères je le regrette mais en
tout cas personnellement moi je ne l'ai
jamais vécu
mais pour autant voilà on est quand même
très attentif à ce qui se passe et et
[Musique]
de France est-ce que oui ou non Grégory
Garcia vous êtes un maire heureux
ah oui totalement et je viens de
terminer mes réunions de quartier avec
les morts pasiens à la suite de
l'annulation des vœux du maire dans le
cadre de notre plan de sobriété
énergétique et financier
de les morts pasiens sont contents
évidemment il y a toujours des choses à
régler et heureusement mais s'ils le son
je le suis aussi et j'ai toujours la
même façon et depuis que je suis mère
depuis 2014 donc oui et 100% oui merci
Grégory guerrier d'avoir été avec nous
je le rappelle mère de la commune de
Maurepas une nouvelle fois très bonne
année dans votre commune